es ist noch mal was anderes ob wir was
neues schaffen und damit diesen neuen
system umgehen müssen wie mit ki oder ob
wir uns so verändern und unsere kinder
dass sich unser begriff vom menschsein
möglicherweise eben auch verändern
[Musik]
vielleicht könnte ich noch daran
erinnern wir haben schon im märz ein
video über konten gemacht das ist ein
pandemie film in dem ein virus ausbricht
und wir haben diesen film mit corona
verglichen und mal geschaut wie
realistisch ist dieser film tatsächlich
wir haben bei mir auf dem kanal mit kai
kupferschmidt zusammen gesprochen und in
zusammenarbeit mit der
max-planck-gesellschaft mit zwei
wissenschaftlern von max planck
instituten
und ich hab mich damals gefragt wollt
ihr von sowas noch mehr sehen also
videos in denen wissenschaftler auf zum
beispiel hollywood film reagieren und
sagen ja das ist wissenschaftlich
tatsächlich korrekt oder hier ist er
hollywood am werk und ihr habt alle
gesagt ja wollen wir mehr von sinnen
also haben wir mit der max planck
gesellschaft zusammen gesprochen und
machen jetzt tatsächlich eine kleine
serie genau dazu und die erste folge
nach dieser pilotfolge quasi ist
tatsächlich einer meiner lieblingsfilme
gitter kam
der ist von 1997 dass ein film denn
einer dystopischen zukunft spielt und in
der genmanipulation total normal ist es
gibt zum einen die validen menschen
diesen genmanipuliert das sind gesunde
große starke menschen die quasi
genetisch genauso gemacht wurden und es
gibt die invaliden menschen die auf
natürliche art und weise geboren wurden
quasi genau so wie wir alle jetzt wir
machen jetzt zu diesem film zwei videos
auf dem kanal der max planck
gesellschaft sprechen wir über die harte
wissenschaft dann geht es um kristall da
geht es darum wie man tatsächlich sachen
manipulieren kann genetisch und wir
sprechen hier über die moralisch
ethischen fragen und spreche jetzt mit
frau professor wenig ii sie ist im
ethikrat von der max planck gesellschaft
und beschäftigt sich schon seit 2005 mit
biotech chambers das stimmt was machen
sie noch alles ich bin völkerrechtlerin
rechts ethikerin uni freiburg und hier
am freiburger frias ja und fragen
demokratische legitimation ethische
entscheidungen sind auch ein
forschungsbereich sehr viel heute anders
ja ich hab den film gattaca mitgebracht
haben sie den damals gesehen 97 schon
ein paar tage her und sie erinnert sich
an den film
ich fand ihn damals spannend ich fand
ihn aber jetzt fast noch besser weil man
einfach sid wie hat sich die welt
entwickelt was haben die damals gewusst
oder geahnt und vorher gesehen und da
kommt ziemlich viel was höchst relevant
ist ich bin sehr gespannt
lasst uns einfach drei bahnsteigen gerne
als erstes schauen wir jetzt eine
filmszene über quasi wirklich
designerbabys das ist jetzt ein gespräch
wie die eltern zum arzt kommen und der
erklärt ja das sind das können sie
machen
das würden wir empfehlen das natürlich
alles in der weit entfernten zukunft wir
können jetzt erstmal über das geschlecht
entscheiden
wir haben uns nur gefragt ob es gut ist
ein paar sachen dem zufall zu überlassen
möchten dafür kennt den bestmöglichen
start wir haben sie mir in uns steckt
schon genug unvollkommenheit und
vergessen sie nicht dieses kind ist
immer noch genau in uns steckt immer
noch genug unvollkommenheit man sollte
nichts dem zufall überlassen es ist
immer noch von ihnen das kind so wird er
dann so werden sie dann überredet die
eltern als quasi das beste die beste
version von ihnen wie wie bewerten sie
das diese designerbaby diskussion jetzt
gerade hier wo er noch eine weit
entfernte zukunft gezeigt wird wo man
sich quasi als eltern dann aussuchen
kann
die und die hautfarbe die und ja auch
gefahr bedient die haarfarbe sportlich
alles mögliche
also ich kann natürlich eltern verstehen
die schwerwiegende erbkrankheiten haben
die bisher kein gesundes kind bekommen
konnten und die dann sagen möchte gerne
kinder aber ich kann mich nicht mehr auf
das risiko einlassen auf das glück
verlassen hier wieder ein kind zu haben
was diese schweren erbkrankheiten hat
für diese ecke wirklich geringe zahl an
extrem viel kann ich verstehen dass man
sozusagen vorher versucht diese
erbkrankheiten auszuschließen
aber ein kind zu produzieren oder zu
modifizieren wie man auto aussucht die
gesichtsfarbe und die der außenlager und
so weiter das halte ich nicht für ein
ziel was wir als menschheit haben
sollten und könnte ich auch nicht
ethisch vertreten also so wie die eltern
wie wir sehen uns gespräch reingekommen
sind nur ein paar sachen sollte man
schon nach dem zufall überlassen ja ich
glaube die eltern sehen das große ganze
sehen würde weil die beschränkten sich
nicht auf schwere erbkrankheiten
entwickelt sich ja auch ganz normal denn
natürlich gezeugte und als ist ja schon
sie haben ja gesund sg 99 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit von herzfehler alles
war ja aber es ist eben eine
wahrscheinlichkeit die keine 100
prozentige wahrscheinlichkeit ist und es
ist auch nicht klar wie schwer der
herzfehler ist und ob man diesen
herzfehler medikamentös beispielsweise
behandeln kann oder durch eine änderung
der lebensumstände und das ist auch die
frage also habermas einmal die frage
gestellt ob zu uns als gattung mensch
nicht auch der zufall gehört und auch
der zufall der entstehung und hier
wollen die eltern ja beispielsweise das
geschlecht festlegen und das ist ja auch
hoch problematisch wenn sie an andere
kulturen denken und sagt vielleicht
jungs sind mehr wert als medien und wir
dann überhang von männlichen nachkommen
hätten das wäre eine ethisch hoch
problematisch sondern auch
gesellschaftlich hoch problematisch und
selbst unabhängig vom infolge schlechter
ist
das kommt ja später auch noch ein film
aber vielleicht guckt man da jetzt mal
einen aber so eine
zweiklassengesellschaft könnte ja dann
entstehen von leuten die alltäglich
intelligenter sind stärker größer besser
aussehend und leuten die halt auf
natürlichem wege entstanden sind die
dann halt normal sind durchschnittlich
so wie wir heute allem auch er wird
praktisch ewig leben ist ein iq springt
jedes skala mehr als 100 prozentiges sie
vermögen aufbauen auch das herz seines
talks mehr als 100 prozentiges
sehvermögen intelligenz über der skala
könnte durch an der wand rennen also
valide menschen werden deine so film
komplett durch die decke gelobt das sind
quasi wandeln die götter unter dem
normalsterblichen invaliden das ist die
zweiklassengesellschaft quasi für mich
ja auf jeden fall vor allem wenn sie es
allein an der genetischen identität fest
waren allein an den wahrscheinlichkeiten
aber das ist auch der glaube an die
genetisch determiniert hat der sich
natürlich auch darin widerspiegelt das
heißt wenn wir in bestimmten genetischen
code haben oder genetische anlagen dann
wird sich das alles realisieren und das
ist das alles entscheidenden dieser
gesellschaft die da dargestellt wird
es ist auch die frage ob es nicht schon
deswegen ungerechtfertigt ist wie hier
unterschieden wird weil möglicherweise
die genetischen anlagen eben gerade
nicht allein entscheidend sind und das
ist ja alles was wir auch wissen dass
genetische anlagen bestimmte
wahrscheinlichkeiten vorhersagen aber
eben gerade uns nicht determinieren das
ist glaube ich auch für unser
selbstverständnis wichtig egal ob in
natürlich gezeugt sind oder sozusagen im
labor gezeugt sind aber irgendwann
mütter haben verständnis der
gesellschaft natürlich dann auch zur
realität das tragen fluchte er sich
selber der der selber in erfüllung geht
also man sieht der verein ist den
gesehen wo die eltern abgelehnt wurden
beim kindergarten weil die versicherung
könnte das ja niemals bezahlen einen
invaliden aufzunehmen
obwohl er eigentlich gar also mit dem
internet ist eigentlich nichts falsch
sondern und das dass das erfüllt sich ja
nicht von alleine
richtig aber das zeigt auch wie sehr uns
mehr wissen dann auch immer wieder vor
neue ethische probleme stellt weil man
könnte ja sagen na ja es ist ja ein
valides argument dass ein arbeitgeber
oder der kindergarten wissen will mit
welchen gefahren zu rechnen ist ja
wollen ja auch vielleicht wissen ob ein
kind an der allergie hat unabhängig ist
von der genetischen disposition um
darauf reagieren zu können
das ist ja das so zu sagen wer die krux
an der genetischen identität oder
ausstattungen dass es nicht mehr
geändert werden kann ja dass wir nur
versuchen können dann die anlagen für
krankheiten zu bekämpfen eben nicht zu
rauchen wenn wir wissen wir haben
flächen erhöhte wahrscheinlichkeit mit
bestimmten krankheiten oder einfach
nicht ja oder general
wir sind der aktuelle status quo in
deutschland jetzt wir können ja schon
ein paar krankheiten vor der geburt
erkennen und können ja dann sogar
entscheidungen treffen
wo ist da die grenze gesetzt aktuell na
ja der gesetzgeber beschränkt sich
darauf zu sagen wenn es um schwere erste
erbkrankheiten geht und die eltern keine
möglichkeit haben auf natürlichem weg
ein gesundes kind zu bekommen
präimplantationsdiagnostik nicht
verboten ist das wird dann aber nochmal
durch eine spezielle kommission die
sogenannte pd kommission im einzelfall
entschieden dass der gesetzgeber
definiert nicht von vorhinein was diese
schweren erbkrankheiten sind sondern
überträgt die verantwortung an ein jahr
pluralistisches gremium was sich den
konkreten fall noch was ja genau
anschauen aber sind extrem schwierige
debatte und wir haben uns in deutschland
zurecht damit lange zurückgehalten und
schwer getan weil ist natürlich eine art
von vorauswahl ist und weil die stimmen
auch gehört werden müssen die sagen wir
wollen nicht menschliches leben in
irgendeiner weise auswählen
andererseits müssen wir auch die stimmen
hören die sagen wir müssen den eltern
leid erspart und dann auch abtreibungen
nicht untersagen ja das ist eine
wahnsinnig komplexe ethische debatte und
ich glaube der kompromiss gefunden wurde
ist sicher nicht perfekt aber ich glaube
er ist für eine gesellschaft
tragbar es gibt am anfang das schon zwei
zitate und das zweite zitat ist ich
glaube nicht nur dass wir ein mutter
natur herumpfuschen werden ich glaube
dass mutter natur will dass wir es tun
ich glaube nicht dass die natur
irgendwas will ja ich würde verstehen
wenn er argumentieren würde ziel unser
ziel muss es sein leiden zu vermindern
und um leiden zu vermindern sollen wird
die natur verändern oder unser ziel muss
es sein die gesundheit der menschen zu
fördern oder die armut zu mindern und
deswegen müssen wir bestimmte dinge tun
und die natur verändern das kann ich
verstehen aber so bin ich nicht
überzeugt dass mit dem ersten teil des
satzes einer der kreml temporis manager
werden wir in mutter natur eingreifen
ich habe das nicht eingeschalten reifen
jetzt ständig in der mutter natur ein
klar und slippery slope haben schon
angefangen
das kann man das gar nicht mehr
aufhalten ich kann sie verstehen das
argument des ribéry slopes anführen und
ich habe das in ethischen debatten auch
zum teil gemacht gerade zum beispiel bei
der präimplantationsdiagnostik ist
wichtig dass wir das nicht ausweiten und
eben nicht das geschlecht selektieren
oder bestimmte augenfarben selektieren
aber ich glaube dass wenn eine
gesellschaft sinnvolle regeln finden
will sie sich auf die auch auf diese
sinnvollen regeln einigen kann und ich
glaube in deutschland haben wir das in
vielen bereichen sehr gut geschafft mann
ist ein alter durch sie müssen natürlich
zum einen filter unterscheiden zins
demokratische staaten oder
undemokratischen staaten in
undemokratischen staaten gibt es
vielleicht auch zum teil noch andere
inszenierungen ja in demokratischen
staaten gibt es zum teil auch in eine
andere kultur der risikowahrnehmung ein
anderes vielleicht erst mal machen und
dann gucken was daraus entsteht und wenn
dann wirklich reden entstehen dann erst
nach steuern das sind zum teil auch
vielleicht historisch bedingte
einstellung zu risiken und zu dem was
hier als eingriff in die natur
beschrieben wird
deswegen ist ja auch so schwierig
internationale regeln zu finden die von
vielen staaten ratifiziert werden weil
auch jedes land mit risiken
unterschiedlich umgehen finde es auch
interessant welche zeit leben also hat
der film schon sehr viel vorher genommen
also es gab chris backus nein damals
noch überhaupt nicht wahr noch überhaupt
nicht so weit das war
noch vorm human genome project zwar zu
19 790 uns sehr viel vorgenommen
ich hoffe nicht dass wir dahin gehen wo
es gibt noch ein paar szenen die noch
viel weiter gehen
aber interessant aber dass die
chinesischen zwilling erwähnt haben
interessant ist auch nicht war nicht nur
die reaktion der
wissenschaftsgemeinschaft sondern auch
die reaktion der chinesischen regierung
ja also der wissenschaftler der dieses
experiment gemacht hat wurde von der
chinesischen regierung öffentlich
kritisiert ich meine hat sogar seinen
lehrstuhl verloren also die fahnder ist
auf jeden fall nicht so witzig das heißt
wenn das ein testballon war dann klar ob
ich war klar dass das nichts ist was
sozusagen einfach gemacht werden kann
das ist hier noch keinen konsens gibt
das ist ja vielleicht auch und positiver
effekt dieses falles
[Musik]
alaba die anfängt den handschuh sieht
sie sich den handschuhe an und merkt
dann gleich ein finger zu viel und man
sieht jetzt auch das plakat und erhält
noch in die hand doch vorher hat fünf
finger er hat an jeder hand sechs finger
und das stück das er spielt ist
tatsächlich so komponiert dass man es
nur mit zwölf länder spielen kann
das ist ja wirklich modifikationen um
etwas neues ein neues level zu erreichen
ich glaube da sind sich alle einig da
wollen wir überhaupt nicht ja ich weiß
nicht ob das niemand will natürlich gibt
es vielleicht möglicherweise anreize
ökonomische anreize militärische anderer
heiz dass manche das vielleicht wollen
ich glaube nicht dass es ethisch zu
rechtfertigen ist weil sie kriegen ja
nicht die einwilligung des jähnigen mit
dem das gemacht wird ja das kind kann ja
nicht einwilligen und ich glaube nicht
dass es ethisch gerechtfertigt ist den
eltern diese verantwortung zu übertragen
und zu sagen ihr dürft ihr euer kind
einwilligen dass es plötzlich zwölf
finger hat nur damit dass andere stücke
spielen kann wir wissen ja bei ganz
vielen interventionen in den natur nicht
was wirklich die folge sein wird das ist
ja auch diskussion bei künstlicher
intelligenz wenn wir einmal super human
künstliche intelligenz haben wissen wir
auch nicht was sie mit uns macht ja und
wir wissen auch nicht beim
wissenschaftler der einen exorbitanten
unmenschliche nico hätte was er wirklich
erfinden würde
wir gehen davon aus dass er das ist die
grundbedingung ist und probleme zu lösen
aber wir wissen es nicht und so lange
bin ich wissen dass der nutzen wirklich
klar ist und wir den wirklich um mit den
risiken abwägen können halte ich das
theoretisch nicht gerechtfertigte sagen
selbst wenn wir 100 millionen menschen
dadurch weiß nicht freie energie geben
könnten wer es trotzdem nicht
gerechtfertig den man einen menschen zu
zeigen dass denn diese aufgabe hat wenn
er dann schreckliches leben das ich
führen muss klar was das beispiel aber
auch vielleicht zeigt ist dass wenn wir
ein finger mehr haben dann die stücke
anders geschrieben werden das heißt also
die aufgaben werden dann auch nochmal
größer also dieser glaube dass wir uns
nur verändern müssen und alle aufgaben
lösen können
ist vielleicht auch naiv aber ich meine
das interessante an dem film ist ja auch
das immer davon ausgegangen wird dass
wenn menschen gehen modifiziert werden
dass es wirklich besser wird
und dabei ist es ja so komplex dass so
ein riesen aufgabe sein von der
überhaupt nicht wissen ob sie jemals
klappt unabhängig davon ob wir sie
ethisch wollen oder nicht wollen schon
genug film vertrauen sie der
wissenschaft immer sehr also sobald
jemand modifiziert das ist ja immer
besser hin und das ist genau und das ist
eine echte welt überhaupt nicht so
welche folgen das vielleicht auch erst
drei generationen später hat wissen wir
überhaupt nicht ich finds auch anders
als wenn wir künstliche intelligenz und
künstliche systeme erschaffen
weil wir eben hier nichts künstliches
erschaffen sondern und selber verändern
und das wird auch das gesamte
selbstverständnis der menschheit
möglicherweise verändern und unser
eigenes selbstverständnis sind das
selbstverständnis derjenigen die eben
nicht modifiziert sind der modifiziert
sind es ist noch mal was anderes ob
etwas neues schaffen und damit die neuen
system umgehen müssen wie mit ki aber
wir bleiben gleich oder ob wir uns so
verändern und unsere kinder das ja nicht
unser begriff vom menschsein
möglicherweise eben auch verändert
ja das ist jetzt dass das gros and build
von jerome der chemie der eigentlich
alles hatte in seinem leben den alles
möglich war
er bindet sich an änderungen während
gleichzeitig vincent schafft obwohl das
nicht schaffen sollte wohl jeder ihm
gesagt hat kannst du nicht schaffen
schließlich bist du bereit dafür der
fliegt dann in der rakete der film macht
dem wunderschönen punkt dass jemand der
eben alles pech der welt hatte in diesem
film also nicht valide ist der keine
genetische modifizierung hatte
herzfehler zu 90 prozent sollte
eigentlich 30 sterben der erreicht am
ende alle seine träume
wer schafft es in die zu den sternen zu
fliegen und derjenige der alles schaffen
sollte der die perfekten bedingungen
hatte er schafft es nicht das natürlich
sehr hollywoods ein bisschen
romantisiert ja aber es zeigt ja schon
dass wenn wir vielleicht ein produkt
sind oder wenn jemand anders unsere
ziele bestimmt dass wir dann
möglicherweise an den zielen oder an den
aufgaben auch er zerbrechen als wenn es
unsere eigenen sind und bei dem der
invalid ist sozusagen der auf
natürlichem weg gezeugt ist waren sehr
eigene ziele und alle haben gesagt das
kannst du nicht das schaffst du nicht in
der gesellschaft wo die genetische
identität so entscheidend ist die
erwartungen die aber eben nicht nur
erwartungen sind wie sie auch heute
vielleicht eltern an kinder haben
sondern erwartungen die zusagen in dem
genetischen code sich materialisiert
haben und deswegen meine ich meine ist
möglicherweise dann nicht mehr in
gleicher weise herr des schicksals zeigt
auch dass in der gesellschaft es einfach
nur darum geht ziele zu erreichen egal
auf welchen wegen er hatte noch um die
ziele zu erreichen werden menschen
modifiziert und die ziele zu erreichen
kann auch mal ein mensch getötet werden
und das ist ja nicht die gesellschaft
die wir wollen und auch die menschen
rechtlich fundiert haben das natürlich
ganz klar die klatsche stream von seinem
historischen zukunftstrend totalitäre
gesellschaft gibt es immer am entfernen
revolution oder halt zumindest gegen die
gesetzeshüter im untergrund zur arbeit
ja ist ja auch wenn es offensichtlich
ungerechtigkeiten gibt die nicht
verändert werden können ist die frage
was ihm sonst bleibt aber das ist
natürlich kein idealer gerechten
gesellschaft zu sagen es gibt eine
gesellschaft in der
diejenigen die sich ungerecht behandelt
fühlen dann einfach die gesetze nicht
beachten sollten und wir müssen ja
versuchen die gesellschaft gerecht zu
machen das eben es ihm möglich wäre das
zu erreichen was er will ohne dass die
gesetze umgeht das ist ganz was war für
sie das im film mit genau das ist was es
für sie die größte messe raus die größte
messe ist dass wir unbedingt verhindern
sollte dass man in ungerechten die
gesellschaften lebt oder ungerechte
gesellschaften zu leisten ich hoffe
nicht dass wir uns in die richtung
bewegen und ich hoffe dass die
menschheit klug genug ist nicht nach
genetischen sozusagen disposition zu
diskriminieren sondern eher zu erkennen
warum und wann es wichtig ist zu wissen
was die genetische disposition ist um
vielleicht gegensteuern zu können um
medikamente anbieten zu können um den
menschen beraten zu können dass er
vielleicht im sport macht ist ein leben
danach ausrichtet wenn das will aber
niemand will eine gesundheitsdiktatur
und niemand will diese art von diktatur
und ich hoffe dass die menschen klug
genug sind das zu verstehen dann auch
durchzusetzen
wunderschön schlusswort einige vielen
dank dass du sie sich gemerkt haben
danke dass ich dabei sein
[Musik]
das hier ist ja nur der erste teil des
videos im zweiten teil des videos gibt's
noch viel mehr um die harte wissenschaft
hintergehen manipulation da spreche ich
mit einer wissenschaftlerin und einem
wissenschaftler vom max-planck-institut
für molekulare genetik in berlin über
eben genau dieses thema beide sind ganz
große experten auf ihrem gebiet und es
geht vor allem darum was tatsächlich
heute schon gängige praxis ist und was
in der zukunft alles möglich sein wird
im bereich genmanipulation wenn euch das
anschauen wollt dann gerne hier klicken
und dann kommt er auf den kanal der
max-planck-gesellschaft und ansonsten
würde mich interessieren was wir in
zukünftigen videos in dieser serie hier
noch alles an filmen uns anschauen
sollen ich habe es gerne unten in die
kommentare alle möglichen filme alles
was wir schon immer mal gefragt habe ob
das realistisch ist oder nicht schreibt
es gerne rein ansonsten vielen dank an
die max planck gesellschaft für die
unterstützung bei diesen videos hier und
an euch vielleicht fürs zuschauen bleibt
hier immer neugierig patrick